in Chapter two has finally hit the big
screen and while the epic conclusion to
the adaptation of Stephen King's 1986
novel
it has largely left fans satisfied a
fair number of critics weren't so
impressed fans of the original book in
the films are likely to shoot down a few
of the pervasive criticisms of the flick
with these arguments several changes
were made to the character of Derry
library resident Mike Hanlon and
criticisms around these changes can be
confusing all of the losers are bullied
but in King's novel Henry Bowers
bullying of Mike was particularly awful
because of Bauer's unrestrained racism
some observers took issue with the fact
that in both movies the racist element
of the bullying against Mike was
substantially toned down leading to
charges of squeamishness on the part of
director Andy muschietti and
screenwriter Gary Doberman
but the racist nature of the Bowers
gangs bullying of Mike is certainly
implied if no racial slurs are used on
screen
[Music]
and it's worth remembering that the
films are set 31 years later than the
novel with chapter 1 set in 1989 rather
than 1958 racism is of course still
pervasive today but it's not a huge
stretch to say that the use of evert
slurs was more likely to be encountered
in the 50s than the 80s and neither film
really suffered from the filmmakers
decision to make the racial aspect of
Bauer's antagonism toward Mike more
subtle the decision was the obvious
byproduct not only of the time period
switch but of adapting a 33 year old
novel
another difference between literary Mike
and cinematic Mike is the fate of his
parents they were incorporated into
Mike's tragic backstory in movies having
burned to death inside a locked
apartment while young Mike watched
helplessly a newspaper headline
conspicuously shown in it chapter 2
refers to a pair of crackheads who set
themselves on fire in front of their
young son but this is later revealed to
be one of penny wisest tricks after the
malevolent entity is defeated the true
headline is revealed and it's made clear
that Mike's parents actually died in an
electrical fire the reason for this
change is fairly obvious for narrative
reasons the poor kid needed a good dose
of trauma into the fake headline place
off of the Bowers gangs racially charged
bullying but one spectacularly wrong
headed review by slates Jack Hamilton
opined that the change itself smacked of
racism he wrote to transform the only
black protagonist from the child of
responsible nurturing parents into the
child of negligent crack cocaine addicts
is far worse than lazy writing it's to
actively draw from a deeply racist set
of cultural tropes we guess he must have
been yawning really wide or looking at
his watch when the true newspaper
headline was revealed of all the
critical gripes levelled at it Chapter
two by far the most common had to do
with the film's nearly three hour
runtime
the film was labeled arduous muddled and
meandering why
for you of course Kings novel is more
than 1100 pages long and a huge amount
of material was left out in bringing the
story to the screen some elements were
combined into details in the film's
story such as the fire that killed
Mike's parents being a clear reference
to the novel's fire at the black spot a
historical event which was used to
illustrate penny wisest centuries-long
influence on Derry those going into it
chapter 2 expecting a brisk breeze aliy
plotted ride to the final showdown
either weren't familiar with the source
material or were expecting Doberman and
muschietti to take far more liberties
than they did the individual and
collective journeys of the losers Club
played directly into how they deal with
the horror of that final confrontation
and if they had been given short shrift
it's likely that many of these same
critics would have been complaining
about that many of it chapter 2 'the
critics also took issue with the
tumorous tone in particular the
wisecracks the adult members of the
losers Club are prone to lobbing at each
other as they prepare to face off
against a heart so unimaginable that
they almost all forgot their first
encounter with it much of the humor is
even intertwined with the horror as with
a brilliant visual homage to John
Carpenter's 1982 classic the thing but
it's clear for some of the characters
the humour is there to mask the fear
it's the old whistling past the
graveyard trope one last so that they
may not soil themselves out of sheer
terror the losers Club is an irreverent
Bunch in both the novel and the film's
in the banter doesn't just have the
effect of entertaining the audience it
also keeps them from going insane if
anything the humor is even dialed down
from the book perhaps the most
frustrating reviews of it chapter 2 were
those that completely whiffed in
pinpointing the film's themes take for
example this excerpt from the review of
NBC News's Noah Berlitz key chapter 2
presents itself as an exploration of
nostalgia and memory the adults
magically forget their childhood
adventures when they move away from
Derry and the movie is about them
reacquainting themselves with their past
friendships and with their true selves
upon their return what the losers are
reacquainting themselves with
voluntarily or not is the horror of
their youth the searing inescapable
trauma which many of us deal with and
which is often buried not by some magic
but as a form of emotional self-defense
doberman spelled this out in an
interview with inverse
think as an adult we all have some
repressed trauma somewhere in us I'm the
same age as the losers in it chapter 2 I
followed up on my own childhood and how
easy it is for memories to fade even the
more traumatic ones like getting details
wrong or asking did that happen when I
can't remember the esoteric ending of
kings novel is practically unfilmable
the filmmakers behind it chapter 2
offered up their own interpretation and
of course many critics jumped all over
it as a monstrous Pennywise menaces them
the losers essentially take away his
power by ridiculing him until he's
physically small enough that they can
rip out and destroy his still-beating
heart at least one observer came
somewhat close to the mark by stating
that the losers sort of bully Pennywise
to death during a conversation with
muschietti only for the director to set
him straight I didn't see it as bullying
so much as it was about reversing the
power of belief on this creature who
uses belief as a weapon to kill his
victims for the first time it's the
losers who have this power and they
start telling him what he is
you're a headless boy you're a weak old
woman and finally they converge on the
concept of a clown which is just the
most helpless and powerless thing the
power of belief is penny wisest power
but it's also his biggest weakness so it
is with all bullies whose victims must
feel weak for them to feel powerful
penny wise is simply the biggest bully
of them all so once that power of belief
is taken away he has nothing left we
just stick together check out one of her
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]